so thank you so much Jeannie for that
kind introduction as Jeannie said my
name is Joe and I am a graduate student
in Rockefeller University so here's just
a brief outline of what I'm going to do
today I'm going to take you through what
I'm talking about and why I think it's
important and then give you some
background which is important for
understanding the paper today by talking
about a new memory before we dive into
the paper itself and talk about what the
authors did in this particular paper and
what they showed and what questions I
think remain outstanding in this kind of
field but before I do that a little bit
more about Who I am so this is a picture
of Joe the scientist as as I was
introduced I'm a third-year graduate
student at Rockefeller University I work
in a field called biophysics which you
could really think of as the interface
between biology and physics the physics
governing the biological molecules in
your body and I moved to United States
six years ago from London where I grew
up and I was born cool I'm not only a
scientist as was alluded to this is a
picture of me from this Christmas
actually where I was hiking a mountain
which is one of the things I really like
doing skiing backpacking being in the
outdoors okay but enough about me um
let's talk about what I'm going to talk
to you about today so what am I talking
about and and why so this is the paper
that I'm presenting to you today
it's called lack of infection in rhesus
macaques infected with SARS cockatoo and
as was discussed prior to me starting
this is a preprint which means it's not
been certified by peer review so I'm
just going to take you through a little
bit more about what that means and
elaborate on what um Heather and Jeanie
was saying at the beginning basically
how science is done if you start out on
the left here you can see that
scientists collect scientific data
obviously and we write it up in a report
and and that report usually is evaluated
by other scientists in this process
called peer review where they give us
feedback
tell us experiments may be extra
experiments that we should do tap the
apps' we should include etc etc
a feedback loop there and then the end
product after that of that peer-reviewed
report is is hopefully published and
hopefully has an impact a positive
impact on society this process of peer
review though can take some time in fact
in some cases it can take up to a year
or more and that's one of the things
that's currently a bit of a problem in
science and especially in the context of
a pandemic where we want policymakers
and the general public to have
up-to-date information as quickly as
possible this process of publishing
material immediately online is really
useful and that's what a preprint
is for those of you for those of you who
have been following the styles of
scientific reasoning in this series of
talks today I'm going to be talking
about an experimental evaluation where
we're using data to test hypotheses and
and get to an answer as a result of that
so why am I talking about this well the
first reason of course is that there's
considerable interest to people who have
had code mid-nineteen because they want
to understand their own personal risk
going forward is it possible for me to
get sick again and that will set to rest
many fears that people have all caused
people to behave differently possibly
but more importantly it's got profound
public health ramifications and that's
because depending on how regularly
people can be reinfected by a virus
different control measures and
strategies are going to be appropriate
and that's because you know if people
are susceptible to being infected again
shortly after being infected it means
we're gonna have to think differently
about vaccination it means we're going
to have to think differently about
social distancing and other public
health measures one final thing before
we start talking about the background to
this paper is that what I'm talking
about today is research done on monkeys
and that deserves acknowledgment and
whenever scientists work with animals we
think about three big things what we
call the 3 R's the principles to reduce
the number of animals used in our
experiments refine our experiments to
maximize the well-being of the animals
in the experiments and wherever we can
replace animals with
our systems be they computational
systems or other systems like cells in a
petri dish and also to replace more
sophisticated animals with less
sophisticated animals we'd rather do
experiments on sli's than on monkeys but
in some cases as with this paper it's
important that we do this work and we
need to understand in as close the
relative to humans as possible there are
lots of organizations involved in
thinking about this these ethical
concerns and kamala treatment how to use
these organisms and I just listed some
of them here they are the university
itself government regulators and
professional organizations which certify
them and and this paper comes from a lab
which which is certified by it by this
organization and is that's the gold
standard in scientific animal care okay
so before we talk about the paper we
need to talk a little bit about how
immune memory works and this is not
really news to any of you because all of
you will know from your own experience
that your immune system remembers past
infections and stops you getting sick
for a second time what I think of when I
think of this is how relatively
unconcerned my parents were when I got
chickenpox right because adults know who
had chickenpox when they were kids that
they're really unlikely to get it again
from their children their immune system
has remembered the virus but causes
chickenpox and makes them very unlikely
inoculates and protects them against
getting sick a second time it's also
obviously the basis of vaccination when
we vaccinate people what we're doing is
we're introducing a modified weakened or
weakened strain of a virus or a pathogen
or we are introducing a fragment of that
pathogen to cause the immune system to
remember it so that when you see it in
the flesh so real your immune system
prevents you getting sick because it's
remembered the pathogen or remembered
the sort of mock version of the pathogen
so what's going on under the hood here
how is your immune system remembering
things
well it's helpful to break the immune
system down into two to the two branches
of it so we have what's called innate
immunity in humans and we have also
what's called adaptive immunity and
innate immunity is a general rapid
response which even starts before you
are infected with the pathogen it's all
the defense's like your skin and mucus
in your respiratory tract that stop you
being exposed to pathogens in the first
place as well as general defenses when
you get hit by a pathogen adaptive
immunity is slower and it's specific and
it involves the production of
specialized antibodies and specialized
immune cells and I'm going to talk more
about what those in the in stealth and
antibodies are but this is the branch of
the immune system which is able to
remember things and so when we talk
about a new memory we're talking about
the adaptive immune system and we're
talking about a very specific memory or
a very particular pathogen so how does
it work well what happens is a pathogen
such as a virus infects us we have a
process going on inside the immune
system where we learn the identity of
that pathogen and then we produce
specialized molecules known as
antibodies they're proteins and we
produce specialized cells which make
those proteins and do other things to
help us become immune and those
molecules and those proteins are present
and help us clear the infection and they
also are present going forward to help
us protect against the same infection
that in the future these are the three
key players we've got antibodies we have
B cells which make antibodies and T
cells which help B cells to make
antibodies and do a whole load of other
things and obviously many a PhD thesis
has been written about any one of these
things so I can't really take you
through them in detail but I just want
to give you an overall outline of kind
of what's going on so antibodies work by
being sticky and I've highlighted the
bits of the antibody which are sticky
I've just circled them in white here um
and really you can think about them
working in in two ways they work in lots
of ways but two really important ways
they work is by sticking to a virus or a
pathogen inside your body and sort of
waving to the rest of immune system over
here over here I've stuck the the bugger
you know you can come and get him um and
they also work by sort of gumming things
up right if you're a virus and you get
stuck all over by an antibody you can
imagine it's not really very easy
you to move around for you to do what
you want to do to interact with the
players you need to interact with
insight the body took to cause an
infection and these cells are obviously
gonna make the antibodies and T cells
are going to support them in that role
and they are also very specific the bits
I've circled on the T cell in the B cell
like the antibody are sticky and they're
sticky only in a specific way so an
antibody that sticky against the measles
virus will not be sticky against a
different virus like flu right and
that's really important it's a specific
response so what happens when you
remember something well we can think of
it a little bit like this so along the
bottom here I'm just plotting advancing
time and initially what happens in my
example here is you get infected on the
Left there's a blue arrow and your
immune system takes some time to respond
to that your adaptive immune system it's
you could think of it as it's finding
the right hand T body
it's calibrating a response it's
figuring out the best way to clear this
virus this pathogen away and so this is
time that elapses and during that time
you're feeling unwell right because the
pathogen is running wild is infecting
you and that's what being sick is right
so then you make your antibodies you
make your b-cells you make your t-cells
and those help you clear the infection
away and then subsequently if you get
reinfected with the virus your immune
system reuses the same cells and the
same antibodies it made the first time
there's no point reinventing the wheel
right it's already done this before it
knows how to get rid of this particular
pathogen the correct antibodies the
correct b-cells to correct T cells to
use and that as a result it's able to
deploy them very quickly to help clear
the infection away but your immune
system is actually even cleverer than
that because it doesn't just use the
same things again it uses the same
things again in a more strong and and
extensive way so if we plot again here
I'm plotting time along the bottom here
and I'm plotting going up the side the
strength of response after the first
infection you have a weaker response
that occurs after or more a larger
period of time whereas after the second
exposure you have a stronger response
that occurs after a shorter period of
time so your immune system is reusing
the cells and the molecules it generated
the first time and it's deploying them
harder and faster to help you beat the
pathogen more quickly and prevent you
going through that period of getting
sick ok so can I bring this to life how
can I make this a bit clearer to you
guys well I have an example or something
in the illustration so if you'll indulge
me for a moment I have a problem for you
and the problem is this Maria went to
the bread store to buy a loaf of bread
for dinner she had two quarters four
dimes three nickels and two pennies and
the total cost of the bread was 82 cents
she promised to make sure she had
exactly one coin remaining after the
purchase so the problem the question I'm
setting for you is which coin did she
have left after buying the loaf of bread
and I think Jeannie is gonna set that up
so you should be able to answer that
question now I'll give you a few moments
the votes are trickling in we've got
about 20 of you so far give you a little
bit longer
we forgot to warn people to bring their
their scratching to the top okay cool I
think we'll leave it there giving you a
minute so what we can see is you did get
the answer right overall it is a quarter
that's the coin she had left over um
great I'm really glad you did
now I have another problem for you
another question for you Maria went to
the bread store to buy a loaf of bread
for dinner she had two quarters or dimes
three nickels and two pennies and the
total cost of the bread was 82 cents she
promised to make sure she had exactly
one coin remaining after that just which
coin does she have left off the purchase
now I'm not actually gonna ask you to do
this because hopefully you've noticed
that it's the same question right so
hopefully if I was to ask you to do this
you would just remember that you've
solved it and you wouldn't have to
recalculate the same problem and that's
a little bit like what your immune
system is doing right so I set you this
math problem and I give you this period
of time to work it out you have to get
your calculator out pull you know pull
your solution together and then you
answer me right and then I ask you the
same question a bit later and you know
you don't need time to work it out again
because you just remember I've already
done this right the answers a quarter
what are you doing Joe right so that's
what your immune system does in a way
right it has his first infection and
it's spending this time figuring out how
to fight the infection and then it comes
up with a good response with a specific
antibody that will target that
particular infection and then if you re
expose it the second time to another the
same pathogen again it's not going to
rework out how to fight that pathogen
it's just gonna reuse its solutions from
before and deploy that response harder
and faster as we did as we saw before
and prevent you from getting sick right
and clear the infection really quickly
okay so
we've said that your immune system
remembers past infections to stop you
getting sick for a second time when we
said that it's a basis of vaccination
but memory is kind of a funny thing
right and I'm thinking about my own
memory when I say that because we
remember some things very very well
perfectly even though they occurred a
very long time ago so this is me on my
first day of secondary school with my
two brothers I think one of them is on
thank you for joining Zach but I'm the
one on the left you can tell I have
dimples and the other two do not
but I'm the point of putting this here
is I remember this day really well right
I remember how I felt
I remember feeling nervous I remember
meeting my teacher for the first time
the walk to school meeting people who
are going to become my friends and it
sort of viscerally quite burned into my
brain right this is not a day I'm going
to forget on the other hand there are
some things that we do very often that
we don't remember all that well at all
and so here is a picture from my phone
of the instructions as to how to open my
mailbox at the University right you know
turn left I said a number of times and
then write a set number of times it's
actually a very difficult thing to do
but the point is I've done this dozens
and dozens of times and I don't remember
it right every time I want to open my
mailbox I pull out my phone and I look
at the picture because I don't remember
how to do it without that prompt so your
immune system isn't very different than
this in the sense that it can remember
some things very well and other things
much less well so the question really is
is cuvee 19 like my mailbox code or is
it like my first day of school is it
something that your immune system
remembers really well or is it something
that your immune system remembers really
poorly and or is it someone between
right that's not a binary there's a
continuum of options between being
remembered really well or not really
well and if we look at other pathogens
we can see that your immune system is is
exhibiting this continuum of memory so a
pathogen like measles the measles virus
is actually extremely well remembered by
your immune system so if you get
infected with measles your immune system
will generate a response and that
response and
specific response will be remembered for
decades and decades and it's why measles
is a very good disease to vaccinate
people against right we vaccinate them
as children and they have immunity
lasting for decades and decades going
going forward from that point and in
fact if you ask immunologist to estimate
how long the memory the immune memory of
measles lasts they might tell you up to
200 years right so this is an extremely
good memory that your immune system
generates of measles and it's why you
get vaccinated only at the beginning of
childhood and you don't need to see the
virus again to be immune from it tetanus
is a bacteria that that causes it you
know infections in people and many of
you may have had multiple tetanus shots
over your life in fact it's quite common
to have tetanus boosters every ten years
or so because whilst your immune system
is pretty good at remembering tennis it
does need periodic reminders and that's
what those boosters serve as to prevent
you forget forgetting tetanus
so tetanus we could put somewhere in
between measles and the last one last
disease I'm going to talk about which is
just a common cold now I should say that
the common cold is actually quite a
complicated collection of different
diseases
it's actually caused by many different
viruses but each one of those viruses is
actually pretty poorly remembered by
your immune system and that's not that
surprising right because we know from
experience that we get colds year after
year after year after year it's not like
being a senior citizen protects you
against getting a cold unfortunately
people throughout their entire life get
sick with colds and that's because your
immune system is not remembering this
pathogen so it can't reuse the response
it used last time it has to start from
scratch every time another result you
get sick right because you have that
delay period where your immune system is
figuring out how to get rid of the
disease so but where does Kovac 19 fit
on this continuum is it closer to the
common cold and the measles end or
summer in the middle and that's really
the problem that these authors in this
paper try to shed some light on okay so
enough background let's dive into
actually what's done in this paper and
what's really going on so what did the
authors do
this paper I'm gonna take right so what
they're doing is they start off on the
left here with some monkeys and what
they do is they initially challenge or
expose those monkeys to SARS cough to
the virus that causes Koba 19 and you
can see the days being counted off on
the bottom here from that period on the
left and I'm going to take you through
the rest of it but just you can see the
days and I've given you an indication
that dpi stands for days post initial
infection and dpr stands for days
because reinfection that second arm will
make more sense in a moment so we've
initially challenged or exposed the
monkeys to the virus and then we're
going to monitor them to see if they get
sick which they should because we've
exposed them to this virus but also make
sure that they get better right so we
want them to experience the disease and
then recover then we're going to take a
subset of those monkeys and we're going
to reach allenge them or reexpose them
to the same virus Oscar cough - and then
basically just ask did the monkeys get
sick right because if they got sick and
it suggests that their immune system
didn't remember the virus and if they
didn't get sick then it suggests that
the immune system did remember the virus
okay so that's kind of in one brush
strokes what what the authors have done
here but how do you do that how do you
go about monitoring these things
what's the matter of being sick or not
sick well there's a few different
measures that the authors are going to
use the first one is swabs and this is
going to be familiar to you because
people all over the world who are
concerned that they have COBIT are going
into hospitals and getting swabs and
then what we do is we look for
scientists look for the presence of the
virus on that swab and that's exactly
what the authors have done here with the
monkey says a periodic sampling of the
monkeys where they're being swamped to
basically monitor to look for can we
find for us in the monkey after we
initially infected after we tried to
reinfect it and when it's sick and when
it's recovered so that's one thing we're
going to do number two we're going to
look for antibodies now I told you that
antibodies are these sticky protein
that your body produces in response to a
specific pathogen so here we're going to
be looking for specific antibodies abies
is is short for antibodies specific
antibodies that respond to the sauce
called 2 virus and we're going to look
for them after we've challenged the
monkeys initially and then after they've
been recharged with this infection so
those that are going to report on kind
of what's going on in the monkeys blood
with the antibodies and what's going on
with the virus but how do we know if the
monkeys actually sick well we can use
the same things that we would use on on
people we can use x-rays so we can take
pictures of the monkeys lungs to see
whether they look healthy or whether
they don't look healthy and chest x-rays
are going to be used by doctors they are
used by doctors all over the world to
look inside your lungs to see do you
have pneumonia is there fluid in your
lungs which is going to be obstructing
your ability to breathe and get oxygen
from the air and breathe out carbon
dioxide that your body's producing so
we're going to take them when the
monkeys should be healthy when we think
it might be sick and then when we're
interested to see whether it's sick or
healthy because we we want to see if
it's a new system remembered the virus
and then the last thing we can do is
what's known as histopathology and
histopathology basically just means
looking at the monkeys lung under the
microscope right having a detailed look
at the microscopic cellular level what's
going on
does the monkeys long look healthy or
does it not look healthy does it look
like the monkey has got the disease or
does it look like the monkey is in the
clear and is pretty healthy so those are
the experiments I'm gonna be taking you
through those four different areas
looking for swabs of the virus looking
at antibodies to see if the monkeys
mountie or an immune response to the
virus looking at x-rays to see how the
monkeys chest looks and looking at
histopathology looking at the monkeys
lungs under the microscope to see
whether they look healthy or not okay so
if that's what they did what did they
find
what does the author's show so before I
show you the data on swabs I just want
to explain to you how it's gonna be
displayed you're gonna be shown on these
graphs I'm sorry about the quality of
the
they're not wonderful that's not my
fault it's the fault of the authors
unfortunately they in the published work
that the graphs are not fantastic
quality but along the bottom we're
looking at Daly's post infections so the
number of days that have elapsed since
the exposure or really exposure to the
virus in the case of DPR which would be
days post reinfection and then along the
side we're looking at viral loads in
nasal swabs and what that really just
means is the amount of virus that we
detected on the swabs that we took from
the monkeys nose I should point out that
along the side is actually a logarithmic
scale and you might be familiar with
this with something like the Richter
scale which is used to measure how
strong earthquakes are basically what it
means is as you go up the scale the
distances between the numbers increases
so the distance between one on this
scale and two is actually only one-tenth
as big as the distance between two and
three and so on and so on so really all
that means is if you if you move up on a
logarithmic scale you're getting a lot
bigger a lot more quickly right it's
just a way that we use it of making
displaying data to shoot so that really
big points don't block out really small
ones cool okay so that's taking through
the graph so let's look at the graphs so
I'm splitting the monkeys here into two
groups
monkeys zero one and two and I'm
displaying the data about their swabs on
the bottom left and I'm the other group
is monkeys three four five and six
return discipline in the middle and a
monkey zero one and two of the monkeys
we just infected once so these monkeys
are not going to be reinfected
whereas monkeys three four five and six
we're going to attempt to reinfect them
we're gonna see what happens so in both
cases after we initially infect the
monkeys add a zero you can see we don't
detect virus in the nose of the monkeys
and then unsurprisingly we see this big
increase in the amount of virus that's
being detected in the swabs from the
monkeys nose that's totally consistent
with the monkeys getting sick the virus
is replicating inside the monkeys
respiratory tract anything
in swaps of the nose and then also
unsurprisingly the virus is reduced
right around a ten post-infection you
can see that the the monkey has
successfully fought the virus what it
looks like right because we're not
detecting virus in the monkey's nose
anymore looks like all of ours has been
killed by the monkey so what's going to
happen when we attempt to reinfect the
monkey well let's have a look so 28 days
post infect post 3 infection if you look
at the middle here that dotted line
represents the point of which we re
expose the monkeys to the virus and what
you can see quite remarkably is that
there's absolutely no increase in the
amount of virus detected in these
monkeys monkeys 3 4 5 & 6 that is after
the re-exposure and that's in stark
contrast to what happened the first time
we exposed the monkeys to the virus well
he saw this big spike in the amount of
virus that was detected now on the right
here what I'm showing you is the
comparisons of the reinfection amount of
virus detected and the initial infection
amount of virus detected
at specific days so so you'll see the
first two bars refer to day zero the
second two to day five day seven day
fourteen post either in Section or
reinfection and the blue dot represents
the bar which is in the initial
infection situation and the RIT and the
orange dot represents a bar in the
reinfection situation now the reason in
the first two you can't see any bars is
because they didn't detect any virus at
this point right and then a day five you
can see under the blue dot there is
virus detected in the initial infection
situation but in the reinfection
situation there's no virus detected same
is true at day seven and a day 14
there's no difference because under both
situations has no virus detected at this
point the monkeys who were initially
infected by day 14 have successfully
cleared the virus out of their system
and so you can't fight any more
so interestingly this is also replicated
I say interestingly it is pretty
unsurprising actually it's also
replicated if you swab the monkey in
other places if you take a swab from the
monkey's throat or a swab from the
monkeys
both of which are places that would
expect to find virus during an active
infection and you can see that what's
happening here is the monkey initially
will see a spike in virus detected by
these swabs but when we reinfect them in
the central two panels you can see that
there's no virus detected
after myriad fact the monkey we attempt
to be in fact the monkey so collecting I
think this show gives you a picture of
that
after we initially infect the monkey it
looks like there's virus being produced
and we can pick it up in swabs of the
monkeys nose and the monkey's throat but
if we allow the monkey to recover and
then we expose it 28 days after the
initial exposure we can't see virus
replicating which suggests that the
monkey is successfully fighting the
virus often preventing it from
replicating and establishing an
infection cool so we've talked about the
first one of my four measures now let's
talk about the second one which is
looking at antibodies okay so we're
looking at antibodies at there is
different points along the progression
of this experiment and what you can see
here is again I'm talking about monkeys
0 1 & 2 these are the monkeys that were
infected only once at the beginning at
day 0 and you can see that excuse me as
the experiment moves on there is this
little lag right where the monkeys are
trying to generate the antibodies that's
the gap in the in the the plots I was
showing you earlier the monkeys immune
system is looking for the right antibody
to fight this virus off looking looking
looking searching it finds it and then
you can see it's produced beginning
around day 14 and then in today 21 and
28 you can see that run to be high
levels of the antibody present so what
about in the situation where we reinfect
the monkey well what you can see is the
first half of this graph is basically
the same right we've initially infected
the monkey you can see it's looking for
the antibody looking looking looking and
finds it around day 14 we get production
of the antibody and then around day 28
when we reinfect these monkeys you can
see that they then kick into a higher
gear right there producing even more
antibodies
and there's this enormous peak at day 42
post initialing section which is 14 days
after the seconded section and the
antibody levels at that point are much
higher than they were 14 days after the
first infection and that's what's
plotted on the on the on the far right
you can see 14 days post initial
infection you've got some antibody
produced but 14 days post reinfection
you have even more antibody produced
which suggests i mean that backs up what
I was telling him earlier about the idea
of the immune response kicking in
quicker and more punchy and being more
effective and more strong the second
time around and that's stopping the
monkey getting sick and so for these
monkeys don't look like in terms of the
antibodies they look like they've
mounted a really effective second
response the second time you've exposed
them and it looks like that is the basis
maybe of why they're not getting sick
right but we so far we haven't actually
taken a look at what's happening in the
monkeys lungs
so let's now do that so let's look at
some x-ray pictures we're gonna look at
at first an x-ray picture from day zero
this is taken before we expose the
monkeys to the virus in the first place
this should be a healthy monkey lung and
you can see hopefully down the middle
you can see the spine of the monkey you
can see the ribs coming in from either
side and you can see the monkeys the
monkeys heart and major blood vessels in
the middle now x-rays on x-rays I'm
first of all I should say I'm not a
radiologist and people trained for a
very long period of time to look at
these x-rays and be able to interpret
them properly but what I do know is
x-rays of the lungs should show up in
dark if there's lots of air right
because it means - the x-rays move
through the lungs more easily and so
that shows up as a black color on the
x-ray and so it's good to have lots of
darker color on your chest x-ray because
it means that your lungs are full of air
and that's what they should be full of
unfortunately it looks like after seven
days post infection if you strain your
eyes and look very closely or if you're
a radiologist I'm told you can see this
the beginning to look like some
cloudiness and that's particularly
pronounced in the red circle but the
authors have kindly drawn on this
x-ray for us now physicians refer to
these as
ground-glass opacities and really what
they are is it's the production of fluid
and information in the lung which is
basically replacing the air in the lung
and causing the chest x-ray to look
lighter rather than darker because it's
not moving through air okay so that's
what's that's what's happening when the
monkeys sick that suggests that the
monkeys developing pneumonia when it's
sick again that's not surprising that's
what happens with a respiratory
infection like SARS cough - so let's
look at what happens from the monkey
gets better a day 28 immediately before
we re challenged it with a new specimen
of the virus so what you can see here is
in the blue shaded circle the lung looks
clearer here doesn't it so we can see
less cloudiness it looks like there's
not fluid appearing in the lungs
suggesting the monkey has got rid of the
pneumonia it may be had and it's kind of
on the way to being healthy again and
then if we look after we re infected
five days after we reinfect the monkey
that clearness remains on the chest
x-ray suggesting the monkey did not
develop pneumonia at the second time
around so the picture we're getting from
x-rays is we initially infected the
monkey its lungs got filled up with
fluid and it got pneumonia it recovered
and when we reinfected the monkey it
doesn't look like that pneumonia
developed it looks like the monkeys long
remain relatively healthy and clear and
that suggested didn't get disease it
wasn't really sick the second time
around so finally let's have a look at
the monkeys lung itself under the
microscope so what I'm showing you here
are two pictures from the monkeys lung
on top is a sort of zoomed out version
of the same picture on the bottom and
I've annotated to show you two important
things in this the first is if there's a
lot of white space on this picture and
that's because there's a lot of air in
the lungs right that's how it should be
the lungs are full of air there
does that allows oxygen into the bus
streaming and excrete co2 out of the
body and then we have these thin walls
around the edge of the air sacs and
you'll have to take my word for it that
those are full of blood vessels and that
and they're very thin and that's
important because it means that the
oxygen in the air sacs can move very
easily into the bloodstream and the
carbon dioxide in the bloodstream can
move very easily into the air sacs to be
excreted and breathed out of the body
cool so what happens when we look at
some monkey lungs taken from seven days
after the initial infection what do they
look like well it's not a pretty picture
we've lost a lot of the clear white
space that should appear on the
micrograph and that's indicative of the
air sacs getting much much smaller
because this is massive inflammatory
response in the lung we've got much much
thicker walls of the air sacs smaller
air sacs and it doesn't look like a
pretty picture it looks like this monkey
is gonna be having trouble breathing
it's certainly not in a healthy place
and if we compare that to a similar long
looked at but we're now looking after
we've reinfected the monkey off it's
recovered and we've reinfected it what
does it look like well it's a much much
better looking long we've still got nice
big air sacs maybe it looks a little bit
different it looks a little bit more
sort of inflamed engorged and the
control but it's certainly a hell of a
lot healthier than the lung in the
middle so if we combine it to the x-ray
the sort of picture we're getting is
healthy lungs at the beginning initially
after initially infecting the monkey the
monkeys lungs unfortunately become
diseased and we get inflammation the air
sacs gets washed out and so this long
isn't working so well we allow the
monkey to recover we re infected and the
lungs don't look bad when they're
infected they look basically normal and
basically quite healthy so collectively
then I think the officer have pretty
convincingly shown that monkeys do not
get reinfected by SARS cough - after a
second exposure four weeks after the
first wing section and we know that
because when we we expose the monkeys
don't detect virus in swabs from the
monkeys noses and throats
we don't detect pneumonia in the x-rays
taken of the monkeys lungs and the
monkeys long stood up healthy under the
microscope cool so that's what the
author's have shown how does that fit in
with what we already know and what
questions remain outstanding well I
think the most important question that
remains outstanding is to do with timing
and this is a really difficult question
to answer it's not that scientists
haven't tried to answer this question or
don't have good experiments for
addressing it it's just it's very
difficult to do these experiments
ideally we'd like to know if we infected
a monkey three or four years ago or five
or ten or fifteen or twenty years ago
and we re expose it to the same virus
does it get sick we'd like to do this
experiment with a time gap not of four
weeks but of four years or four decades
to understand how long the immunity is
lasting how long is that memory lasting
but of course that's not possible with a
virus like Koba 19 which has emerged in
the past six months though we didn't
know that this virus existed in five
years ago we couldn't have been
infecting monkeys to do these
experiments five years ago because the
fact that we didn't know that the virus
existed so we severely limited in our
ability to look backwards enable it to
enable us to do these experiments to
address how long immunity really lasts
but we do have an important data point
from this experiment which suggests that
at the very least your immune system is
capable or at the monkeys immune system
which is extremely similar to yours is
capable of remembering an infection full
stop and then there's a second question
to do with whether immunity is going to
last in its entirety or whether it might
be remembered in some degrees so even if
you mmunity expose fully are you
protected by some degree by by the
memory that you have so is it even if
you get sick a second time is it
possible that you get sick less severely
than you got sick the first time you got
infected because these memories are not
a binary yes you remembered no you
didn't remember thing as a continuum and
then of course we need to think about
the public health considerations of this
if we do develop a vaccine and all
people going to need regular treatment
with this vaccine or are they going to
be able to be vaccinated just once and
can we use a measure unlike antibody
levels to predict whether someone needs
to be vaccinated or not cool so if you
weren't listening to anything I just
said over the last 40 minutes what's the
answer to the question can I get co19
twice well what I would say is this in
the short term it's extremely unlikely
we've seen that from the monkey over a
period of months it's unlikely that your
immune system is going to forget it the
monkeys immune system certainly did not
but we're not sure about when immunity
might expire in the medium term or the
long term because we haven't been able
to do this experiment yet we don't you
didn't know this virus existed more than
six months ago and if we look to the
best evidence that we can kind of
speculate with it would come from
looking at viruses which are similar to
SARS call - like the original SARS virus
and MERS Middle East respiratory
syndrome if we look at those viruses we
have some data it's not it's not
foolproof and it's not comprehensive but
we have some danger suggesting that
immunity lasts around two to four years
for these related corona viruses so it
wouldn't surprise me if it was a similar
kind of time length with this virus but
we don't know it is different it's a
different virus and it could be longer
it could be shorter that remains for
scientists to establish rest assured
there's lots of people pretty hard at
work on this problem so that's it from
me I just like to say a big thank you to
the whole of the d4p team from all over
the world and the US and invite
questions from any of you guys if my
talk has formed them so thank you very
much